una gran victoria para el presidente
norteamericano jobvite antes en esta
votación los 169 los 930 se aprueba el
proyecto de ley con las amenazas el
masivo plan de infraestructura fue
aprobado por el senado después de años
de debilidad
estamos en el auge de la década de la
infraestructura que realmente creo que
va a transformar a eeuu y box transform
marc 1.2 billones de dólares han sido
avalados para renovar carreteras puentes
puertos y aeropuertos pero también para
los circuitos de agua potable y
electricidad y para renovar el internet
de alta velocidad 550 mil millones de
dólares serán inyectados en nuevos
gastos federales aún por definir otros
450 mil millones de fondos ya están
atribuidos a otras partidas un día antes
el secretario de estado
anthony blinken había llamado la
atención sobre la importancia de aprobar
este plan por favor y jaén por oneworld
nos estamos quedando atrás del mundo y
nuestro
lentamente se están acercando a nosotros
pueden que los pinos
mary's en algunas áreas ya están por
delante en desmarques es importante
porque si esta tendencia continúa
seremos menos competitivos en un mundo
más competitivo
el plan es el fruto de un raro consenso
entre demócratas y republicanos la
próxima batalla de bailén será la
inversión de 3.500 millones de dólares
en infraestructura humana por eso
necesitaría aumentar impuestos sobre
sociedades sin seguridad de que sea
aprobado